Geplant war das Ganze so nicht.
Doch die Raumsonde “Beresheet” hat für
die ersten Mondbewohner gesorgt: einige tausend
Bärtierchen.
Die israelische Raumfahrtmission war im April
schiefgegangen und die Sonde zerschellte anstatt
planmäßig zu landen.
An Bord: Äußerst robuste Überlebenskünstler,
die bereits einige Aufenthalte im Weltall
gut überstanden haben.
Wimmelt es auf dem Mond also jetzt vor Bärtierchen?
Wahrscheinlich schon, aber in einem sehr seltsamen
Zustand.
Clixoom Science & Fiction, gibt es täglich
spannende Science-Videos, abonniert den Kanal,
aktiviert die Glocke.
Nur dann verpasst ihr nichts.
Los geht’s!
Und vielen Dank für diesen super spannenden
Themenvorschlag, der aus unserer coolen Telegram-Community
von Morpheus stammt!
Die Telegram-Community findet ihr hier unter
dem I und in der Videobeschreibung!
Herzlich willkommen!
Sie haben acht Beine und ihre Form erinnert
an Gummibärchen.
Doch sie haben quasi Superkräfte.
Egal ob radioaktiver Unfall, gigantische Chemiekatastrophe
oder die komplette Austrocknung der Erde:
Die Bärtierchen würden das alles überstehen!
Sie sind wahre Überlebenskünstler - und
das liegt an einem speziellen Schutzmechanismus
an ihren Genen.
Und alles könnte ihnen jetzt zugute kommen.
Denn einige tausend dieser Überlebenskünstler
befinden sich wohl seit dem 11.
April auf dem Mond.
Dort hingekommen waren sie an Bord des israelischen
Raumfahrzeuges “Beresheet”, das laut Plan
eigentlich auf dem Mond landen sollte.
Sieben Wochen lang war die Sonde unterwegs,
doch beim Landemanöver fiel der wichtigste
Motor aus - und das in der letzten Minuten.
Das Raumschiff zerschellte.
Aus der israelische Traum, als vierte Nation
auf auf dem Mond landen.
Doch die Passagiere an Bord - auch bekannt
als Wasserbären - haben höchstwahrscheinlich
überlebt - da sind sich Fachleute eigentlich
ziemlich sicher.
Denn sie kommen nicht nur ganz ohne Sauerstoff
aus, sondern können sowohl Vakuum als auch
extreme Kälte gut überstehen.
In der Fachsprache ist von einer sogenannten
“Kryptobiose” die Rede - ein todesähnlicher
Zustand, bei dem die Tierchen ihre Stoffwechselaktivität
herunterfahren und so extremen Umweltbedingungen
trotzen.
Ein Forschungsteam der Universität Stuttgart
hatte einige Bärtierchen vor mehr als zehn
Jahren mit einer russischen Rakete ins All
geschickt.
Die Lebewesen verbrachten zehn Tage im All.
Einige von ihnen ließen sich ohne Probleme
wiederbeleben.
Doch wie kann das sein?!
Dazu ein Forscher von der Universität Tokio,
Takekazu Kunieda: “Sie können einfach so
zwischen Leben und (beinahe) Tod hin und her
wechseln.
Das ist unglaublich.”
Er war dem Geheimnis der Bärtierchen im Jahr
2017 auf die Schliche gekommen: Eine Schutzhülle
rund um das Erbgut der Lebewesen fängt alle
schädlichen Einflüsse ab.
Konkret handelt es sich um ein Protein, das
das Erbgut vor Schäden bewahrt - in der Fachsprache
Dsup genannt.
Vorstellen kann man sich das tatsächlich
wie eine Art Superhelden-Cape.
An der DNA befestigt ist es durch elektrische
Anziehung; aber das eben nur an der einen
Seite.
An der anderen Seite flattert es locker herum
und sorgt so für den Schutz.
Das hatten die Wissenschaftlerinnen und Wissenschaftler
bei dem strahlungstolerantesten aller bisher
bekannten Bärtierchen, dem sogenannten “Ramazottis
varieornatus” herausfinden können.
Zurück zu den Bärtierchen, die jetzt auf
dem Mond “leben”.
Sie waren tatsächlich Teil einer Art “Bibliothek”.
Die Stiftung “Arch Mission” hat sich zum
Ziel gesetzt, wichtige Infos über die Menschheit
als eine Art “Sicherungskopie der Erde”
im Weltall zu hinterlassen.
Ganz vorne mit dabei: der Unternehmer Nova
Spivack.
Er hatte in der Vergangenheit in Quarz gravierte
Bücher ins All geschickt.
Und zwar im Handschuhfach eines Tesla-Roadsters,
den Elon Musk im vergangenen Jahr (2018) als
Werbegag in den Weltraum geschossen hatte.
Doch auch bei der israelischen Mission hatte
Nova Spivack seine Finger im Spiel.
Er hatte dazu nicht nur die Bärtierchen als
Überlebenskünstler ausgewählt, sondern
auch tausende Werke der Weltliteratur.
Diese hatte er auf Nickel Scheiben gravieren
lassen.
Mit an Bord der Sonde waren auch DNA-Proben
von 25 Menschen und Spuren von exotischen
Pflanzen.
Spivack ist sich sicher, dass die Bärtierchen
die Explosion und den Absturz auf dem Mond
gut überstanden haben: “Wir glauben, dass
die Überlebenschancen der Bärtierchen äußerst
hoch sind".
Er hofft, dass die Sonde die Bibliothek beim
Einschlag ausgeworfen hat und sich diese nun
in der Nähe der Absturzstelle befindet.
Doch die Lebewesen befinden sich ja in einem
getrockneten Zustand.
Vor ihrer großen Reise hatte man sie in einen
Ruhezustand versetzt, indem man ihnen Wasser
entzogen hatte.
Sie gehen dann in die sogenannte Tönnchenphase
über und aus den Bärchen werden eben Tönnchen.
In diesem Zustand überleben sie nahezu eben
alles.
Die Bedingungen auf dem Mond sind allerdings
äußerst ungeeignet für eine Reanimierung.
Denn um wieder aktiv zu werden, zu wachsen
und sich zu vermehren, brauchen sie Nahrung,
Sauerstoff und Wasser.
Bärtierchen und ihre Alien-DNA.
Hammer Video mit nochmehr Infos.
Anklicken, anschauen und Weltraum-Wissen von
Astro-Comics TV abonnieren.
Sehr sehr cooler Kanal.
Bis dann, bleibt dran!